okay by the way the Rio Terry nice to
meet you pleasure
give me a second okay what's your name
sir okay and what's your story
well I found love with a woman and she
ruined my life well my story on how I
got to San Diego or how I got here
well I sold my mansion for a penny you
know I've
had my ups and downs but I won't blame
anybody I I had
I've been battling alcohol for some
years now and I've had a house I've had
a couple houses in a couple cars in a
couple of but alcohol eventually drug
dragged me down so I've had to start
over and I'm in the process of starting
over again can I ask a follow-up
question
of course so you said that alcohol we
would say the main reason right
well is the only reason for everything
my dads are not all his father's at a
college everyone in my family's not fond
so I had to make sure I carry the family
tradition it started off as
a casual social thing like smoking an
occasional cigarette every now and then
at a party or whatever your reason is
and then then it became its own monster
I not sure if there's another adequate
word for it but it becomes it becomes it
becomes its own thing eventually
eventually what do you think people
think I mean when I I've had friends in
the car with me and like I've seen a
homeless person and I've stopped and I
given the homeless person money and
they've told me like why would you do
that they're gonna spend it on this and
I'm like we don't know that is something
you don't know what they're gonna spend
it on yeah exactly you could ask them if
it bothers you that much
[Laughter]
they say crack then you snatch it back
other thing is having a certain level of
commitment a certain little level of
status and then losing that and starting
all over and then getting it back and
starting all over again that sucks
now
you know I started off with it you know
a lot of people like to think that it
would be that I had a bad childhood or
something like that it wasn't like that
I mean I loved my childhood I loved my
mother I loved my family
you know and a good upper a great
relationship I was very successful in
business its unofficially about nine
years of college in one night in just
one night I lost my wife I lost my
daughter
I lost my house I lost my car I like to
say that oh we can get through anything
you know it if you can get through it I
just told you you're not human
some things you just you just can't get
through I don't care who you are you
know a series of events could knock
anybody down I'm life to me now it's
really kind of such a bore I mean the
only life I know is the one that I have
right in front you know how do you go
about going into recovery trying to
be clean it's over but there's no reason
I get again Who I am
yeah there's nobody to give it to try to
kill myself and a full prescription of
xanax 60 kilograms of a prescription of
trazodone I woke up well-rested I can't
even kill myself I guess there's some
sort of a purpose of something for me
because I'm still here there's gotta be
he's there's no way I should live
through that there was a beating I went
to if that meeting a guy came up to me
he says I heard your story I learned it
about three and a half years ago I was
at path fibers that was a recovery home
I went to it and he says well I heard
the story there then I heard it again it
ran through my mind while I stood up the
Coronado Bridge right before he jumped
and I didn't jump that day that's three
and a half years ago I got six guys I
sponsor and all know your story you ever
think for long as it's your life maybe
not about yours anymore maybe it's not
about you if my story can save a few
lives that's that's enough purpose in
itself you know what I have found
purposes that is it yeah you gotta
understand that not everybody is evil
out of here you know and if you keep on
turning you whine die you know check
your blind eye on somebody that could
help resolve the whole problem because
there's nobody that can help a homeless
person better than a homeless person
nobody it's gonna help the attic better
than an attic
yeah I don't know find some way don't
give up on us because some of us haven't
given up and I have it really hard to
say that
if you want to provide help help them
with the bus pass but make sure you keep
yourself safe when you come out here I
can't tell you how many volunteers I see
out here with sneakers and tennis shoes
sorry man but you're wearing them too
needles poked through those shoes real
easy be safe you'll come out here and
think and then it's just you know walk
in the park because this is literally
one of the most dangerous places you
could be right there now right there
every 20 minutes they're getting called
for an overdose every 20 minutes in the
year 2017 lawns on 17th Street there was
300 overdoses on 17th Street alone
that's what Street that way I counted 39
people last week it sat down to buy some
how many people do I know is 39 to my
friends dead five years I'm sorry about
that man all of us know we're probably
some of the best at CPR honestly we do
not know how to do that well the reason
I got out here is because
if you lie cheat or steal things from
yourself usually doing it to somebody
else at the same time when you've what
goes around comes around
so we're gonna have you at any time and
according to what you've done I did
stupid things to myself I've been rich
I've driven nice cars nice houses but um
when you get to the point where you
really don't think you're getting
anywhere and you're losing connections
with people like with alcohol or any
substance accordingly mine was alcohol
and it just drove me to be
self-contained and I ran my life it
didn't make any friends I don't have any
family there they all lost those when I
was a kid you know my dad dad was five
my mom was a heroin addict I advanced
but I'm one of the ones around here that
doesn't really need any help I get my
pension and Social Security that was in
the Marine Corps a while and I forgot it
out of that I just I just kicked around
I don't want to be inside I really want
to hear anybody's rhetoric or about the
Bible I've read it I know what it says
love others as you want yourself to be
loved and if you can live by those rules
most likely you're gonna succeed in
whatever you do make sure you keep a
people hold of the people around you
making mistakes those people are the
only ones that are gonna be forgiving
towards you anyway I've been out here a
while about 12 years and I've helped a
lot of people off the streets
cuz I have sound mind I'm a psychologist
when Sandy or state but if you get into
your own self I don't think about what
you're doing you might be able to help
somebody else figure out what they might
do for themselves
[Music]
we're human beings just like everybody
else
we somebody's mother brother sister
daughter child with grandfather's
grandmother's with all of that but
looking down on us and thinking there
were always guilty you've got some of
the best people in the world homeless
I've met some angels and missing people
so so kind of so sweet and so loving and
they don't have a job and they sleep out
here on the sidewalk with me and on the
flip side we have the meanest the
dirtiest the cruelest institutions tend
to let out the bad people in form right
with the homeless population in so we
have a lot of bad ones and we also have
a lot of good ones this is called the
bottoms I says the bottoms of San Diego
we are connected to the earth we are the
people that set the bottom and when
you're at the bottom you see people
struggling and you see people having a
hard time the real person what you see
brought the pretty glamorous rich money
all the beautiful things houses homes
cars and all that then the true feelings
come out one thing this in San Diego
would needs to be done we need to be
able to use the bathroom we need a place
to wash our clothes we need a place to
wash our bodies because you can't get a
job if you're not clean because you
don't have no self esteem to deal with
an interviewer if you're dirty and
smelly
so that's the main thing help us help
ourself and we need to be able to be on
the inside like right now this year is
sending its bitter cold a lot of people
are dying I'm an elder man I'm City
years old you know weather hurts people
kills them I believe in God I believe in
good and I'm not perfect you know what
none of us are so I try to keep the
peace and you know trying to keep people
inspired it there is good and there is
bad blood you know try to stay more good
I'm native Californian uh born out in
Northern California and I think the rent
just got high too high for me to to make
it you know I get a thousand eleven
hundred hours a month if your rents
gonna be a thousand you know so I think
that's basically learner's can't afford
the rent you know I'm just missing love
long story short what's not flying love
again I'm back in the wind with the
money but but without love that you
can't allows you kind of confuse you
don't know but we love the woman always
made sure I was taking care of food
shelter driving made me go to work and
give her the whole check but the point
is always had a job I'm missing love
love - love is how I got out here on
these streets I was never out here I
can't remember one time I was homeless
people I have a college degrees masters
doctorates can end up in these trees
hope it don't matter
so I met you here last time you were in
the first episode yeah so I guess can
you give us a follow up are ya me my
boyfriend got a face ray I'm blessed and
I'm
a baby and stuff we're doing good though
that's all I'm happy we've saved a lot
of money up where we got our own spot by
yourself I'm so glad to see you doing
well care for the homeless people and I
try to do my best to help them because I
know how it was is that why you're out
here today I know I lost my wife two
years ago to cancer and it was a pretty
devastating you know 27 years together
you know my life is good you know a good
working job and you know doing the right
thing you know try to stay on top of it
but he got it got hard he got really
hard you know and I I got the poor I
couldn't go home anymore we did the same
house for 20 years you know how that
goes so I had to go and I packed up my
stuff one day and provide all my
belongings in and storage and took a
leave of absence from my job and I
my life I'm a chronicle whole is with
physical and mental disabilities I was a
caregiver in San Diego hospice so after
that I get I went sick
unfortunately I'm not able to work
anymore so I come to this situation as a
human being we fight and requests
raising the voice to the authorities to
help us out to be out of the streets
this unfortunately you know until right
now I'm still waiting for their health
what's the hardest thing you've been
here since you've been on the streets oh
my lord
crying that's the horrible thing that I
ever see I never taught in my life to
see anything not like that I never see
any crime like that and until right now
I'm homeless
how would they kill the people they're
stealing in a horrible situation how is
this how is the city deteriorated and
I'm so happy you know in in media about
this you know conversation that we have
you know between you and me and these
cameras I hope they can you know a good
a good Samaritan coming and give me that
hand did I really need to be hiding here
not only for me for the rest of the
people as a human being that we are we
proud to be an American that's what
really we need and I'm proud to be Who I
am
everyone I mentioned in part one of this
how hard it was to decide to film
the episode and it was just as hard if
not harder this time I tend to overthink
things when it comes to touchy subjects
and vulnerable faces like this one I
just really think that there are a lot
of misconceptions when it comes to the
homeless community and I also believe
that the best way to solve problems like
this is to ask hard questions and share
little stories so I hope you learned a
lot by hearing these stories because I
know I did I'm gonna do everything I can
to give back to my community here in San
Diego and again I hope you'll do the
same with yours that's pretty much it
thank you guys again for watching
be kind stay safe and I'll see you next
week
[Music]